i
[Música]
ah
en colombia la pasada semana el
ministerio de salud aprobó las normas de
bioseguridad para la reapertura de las
instituciones educativas destacan la
toma de temperatura el permanente
suministro de alcohol glicerina dow una
ventilación adecuada así como una
distancia de seguridad de 2 metros este
plan piloto se está realizando de forma
alterna con alumnos en casa y otros de
forma presencial una vuelta a clases que
en bogotá la capital por ejemplo ya se
ha producido en colegios autorizados y
también en alguna de las universidades
más prestigiosas sin embargo el regreso
a los colegios genera dudas en un país
tan desigual como colombia según un
estudio de escalando y la red paz paz el
55 por ciento de las instituciones
educativas no cuentan con suficiente
agua y jabón una cifra que llega al 76
por ciento en el caso de las escuelas
públicas pero además de la higiene
también hay datos que muestran que el 63
por ciento de estudiantes de colegios
públicos no tienen acceso a computador
ni tampoco a internet condiciones que
los expertos aseguran que pueden causar
un aumento en la brecha de oportunidades
entre los estudiantes colombianos
[Música]
según el calendario escolar del gobierno
el 5 de octubre es la segunda fecha para
iniciar las clases a distancia en
venezuela sin embargo en muchas de las
escuelas públicas aún se encuentran en
la etapa de inscripciones y no han
comenzado las clases oficialmente los
colegios privados se iniciaron el 16 de
septiembre la educación vía online la
federación venezolana de maestros y sus
27 sindicatos convocaron una
manifestación el mismo 5 de octubre para
expresar que nos van a impartir clases
hasta tanto se les faciliten los
recursos tecnológicos se regule la
energía eléctrica y el internet
necesario para dar la educación a
distancia y que tampoco van a enseñar en
clases semipresenciales porque los
centros educativos no están adecuados
para evitar el kobe 19 los docentes que
trabajan para escuelas públicas
presentaron al gobierno un pliego de
peticiones donde pidieron herramientas y
condiciones para teletrabajar también
están exigiendo un aumento salarial ya
que los educadores ganan entre 0.3 y 0.5
centavos de dólares mensuales
[Música]
el ministerio de educación chileno
volvió a presentar un plan de retorno
voluntario a clases asegurando que sólo
los colegios que cuenten con las
condiciones sanitarias y los requisitos
establecidos estarán autorizados para
abrir de hecho de los 280 que han
solicitado solo se han concedido 60
autorizaciones la semana pasada en la
comuna de pirque hubo un intento fallido
en el que abrieron cinco colegios en
alguno de ellos no apareció ningún
alumno en otros apareció un solo alumno
y al ver la cantidad de prensa convocada
salió corriendo y el que el colegio que
más alumnos registró fue un total de 20
este lunes en la parte más acomodada de
santiago cuatro colegios vuelven a abrir
las puertas y al menos en uno de ellos
se registraba más de la mitad de los
alumnos convocados el gobierno lleva
semanas intentando impulsar la vuelta a
clases para que los padres tengan un
lugar donde dejar a sus hijos y retomar
así sus empleos y también en un intento
de acortar la brecha digital que ha
supuesto que aquellos alumnos más
vulnerables que no tienen acceso a
internet se hayan quedado atrás en
conocimientos en las clases no
presenciales
[Música]